Domon up by Grant Williams
[Music]
[Applause]
Edwards with a three hurt an injured
Solomon in the first half he will not
return he was hit by a taco fall on the
drive to the basket three on the way by
Edward second on this team assists per
game only to Matt Dellavedova last
season Edmond Tigers another free
in-store feature posed by the rookie out
of Purdue to open up his third quarter
more seasons and pistons great setting
Edwards another 300 a oh my threes devil
do it
Edwards another three this went off four
triples for Edwards in this third
quarter that one was drifting to his
left
I brought an enes kanter in free agency
looks like it's gonna be long three by
Edwards he scored four minutes in third
quarter something's on a 15-point lead
Edwards again oh my goodness in
situations like that you wanna you gotta
give yourself up you got to try and get
to the basket toad we're good
another triple and Edwards and the
suffix on a 7758 lead
after the Suffolk speaks with a 19-point
lead Williams square is a fake surgery
back to Edwards he doesn't hesitate any
score
[Applause]